montag 16 märz 2020
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
besucht am ersten tag der landesweiten
ausgangs beschränkungen die spar
zentrale in st pölten damit der
lebensmittelhandel auch weiterhin
problemlos aufrechterhalten bleibt
kommen in handelsketten wie dieser
bundesheer soldaten zur unterstützung
zum einsatz
seit elf tagen sind die angestellten
dieses supermarktes bereits
ununterbrochen am arbeiten und somit im
dienst der gesellschaft 50
bundesheersoldaten der großteil davon
grundwehrdiener sind seit vier uhr früh
im einsatz um die belegschaft zu
entlasten
geschäftsführer alois huber weiß das
sehr zu schätzen und gibt auch gleich
entwarnung lebensmittelknappheit besteht
keine toiletten wenn ich jetzt die
aktuelle woche im vergleich mit der
woche des vorjahres und wie aus 249.000
eine million 04 und 70.000 einheiten
machen und zu 430 steigerung bei diesem
großartigen ähnliche sandra küchenpapier
küchenrollen da sieht man es auch
verteidigungsministerin tana zeigt sich
sichtlich stolz auf die leistungen der
soldaten und bedankt sich vor ort für
deren einsatz
das österreichische bundesheer ist immer
die strategische reserve der republik
kommt in den verschiedensten bereichen
zum einsatz bei assistenz einsetzen wenn
uns die polizei benötigt sowie bei
grenzkontrollen jetzt gerade aktuell an
den verschiedensten orten insbesondere
im bundesland tirol
desweiteren immer dann wenn wir auch
angefordert werden von den
gesundheitsbehörden und hier als
unterstützungsleistung in einer
besonders herausfordernden situation um
die versorgung der österreichischen
bevölkerung auch sicherzustellen sind in
den verschiedensten lebensmittel lagern
des einzelhandels 650 bis 700
soldatinnen und soldaten im einsatz geht
hier ein ganz ganz großes dankeschön all
denjenigen zu sagen die sich hier um die
österreichische bevölkerung bemühen